that you bought the argument is that you
bought yourself some time you didn't
teach us to prepare hospitals you didn't
use it to ramp up testing Fran so you
said oh you're so disgraceful okay okay
hold it one second any other questions
for many other people okay thank you
very much everybody
millions does you witness who are scared
right now what you say to Americans
we're watching you right now
you're scared I say that you're a
terrible reporter that's what I say and
in fact we'll give you a list what we
did in fact part of it was up there we
did a lot look you know you're a fake
you know that your whole network the way
you cover it is fake it's just I wish I
wish we had a fair media in this country
and we really don't many times that the
u.s. is doing far better than any other
country when it comes to testing yes why
does that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if everyday Americans are still losing
their lives and we're still seeing more
cases every day
well they're losing their lives
everywhere in the world and maybe that's
a question you should ask China
don't ask me has China that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please
you've said repeatedly that you think
that some of the equipment that
governors are requesting they don't
actually need you said New York might
need that might not need 30,000 you said
it on Sean Hannity's Fox News you said
you said why don't you act in a little
more positive it's always trying to my
question to you how did you get you and
you know what that's why nobody trusts
the media anymore how is that going to
anything I didn't hear me that's why you
used to work for The Times and now you
work for somebody else look let me tell
you something be nice
what sir why are you saying that to me
specifically I'm telling you I'm not
saying it's specifically to anybody I'm
saying it to anybody that would ask a
nasty question please go ahead okay
anybody else please go ahead in the back
please it's okay
y'all I have two questions mister next
next place but you didn't you called on
me I did and you didn't respond and now
I'm calling on sorry just a young lady
in the back please I just let my
colleague okay ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much appreciate it thank
you very much nearly 200 dead 14,000
you're sick millions as you witness who
are scared right now where you say to
Americans we're watching you right now
you're scared I say that you're a
terrible reporter that's what I say I
think it's a very nasty question and I
think it's a very bad signal that you're
putting out to the American people the
American people are looking for answers
and they're looking for hope
and you're doing sensationalism and the
same with NBC and Comcast I don't go I
don't call it Comcast I called Comcast
let me just have for whom you work let
me just say something that's really bad
reporting the heat and humidity is it
dangerous for you to make people think
they would be safe by going outside in
the heat
considering that so many people are
dying in Florida considering that this
virus has had an outbreak in Singapore
places that are Laden are we read the
new headline is Trump as people to go
outside that's dangerous here we go
same old group you're the President and
people tuning in to these briefings they
want to get information and guidance and
want to know what to do I'm the
president and you're fake is I know you
well because I know the guy I see what
he writes he's a total faker so why was
the United States not prepare visual
testing we were
the only thing we weren't prepared for
was the the media so we have a lot of
very angry media all around this room
and they want one of these seats but
because of social distancing we are
keeping them empty and they are keeping
them empty will there ever be a time
when all of those really angry angry
people who don't like me much to start
off with but now they really don't like
we will there ever be a time when these
seats are full like full to the brim
like it used to be where people are
almost sitting on each other's left how
many people had died in the United
States keep your voice down please keep
your voice down
did you know how many how many how many
cases were in the United States I did a
band where I'm closing up the entire
country how many people died how many
people died in the United States and yet
I closed up the country and I believe
there were no deaths zero deaths at the
time I closed up the country nobody was
there and you should say thank you very
much for good judgement